the plastics revolution starts with a
Victorian billiard ball since then
plastics have taken on a bewildering
number of shapes and colors and they've
changed our world in a bewildered way
not all of those for the better a
problem skies ocean rescue campaign aims
to fix it begins in East London these
are the young likely beginnings of the
the plastics industry as we know it
today in fact it was kicked off by a
Birmingham inventor called Alexander
parks in 1862 he was responsible for
exhibiting for the first time a
commercial man-made plastics material
and that was called Parkerson well I'm
actually gonna make some parkas in under
the watchful gaze of Professor - have to
make sure I get it right and the first
stage is to make some gun cotton it's a
simple recipe mix sulfuric and nitric
acids in an icy bath to cool the
reaction then add a cellulose in this
case cotton stir then leave to soak
after that wash the acid off with a
bicarbonate then leave the nitrated
cellulose to dry so this is some
previously dried-out nitrated cellulose
make it into a plastic we've got to add
a plasticizer like Alexander parked it
in this case we're going to use camphor
and mix it with a solvent and hopefully
get some plastic that leaves you with a
dissolved plastic pour it out and wait
for it to dry oh oh and I've managed to
tear it but we have nonetheless
emphasized the first man-made plastic
wherever you turn today that 50 sure to
be a modern plastic in use in 1907
bakelite the first truly synthetic
plastic was invented in New York by the
1930s all sorts of new plastics were
being created this paratrooper floating
down to welcome Mother Earth as
depending on plastics to get him there
safely during the Second World War
parachutes were made from nylon hand
grenades encased in bakelite and the
cockpits of airplanes were made from
perspex your resume and
containing hundreds of plastic parts the
war ended and the huge industrial
plastic machinery was redirected at
consumers the living room was
transformed decade by decade as plastics
colonized our homes
by the 1960s plastics was a big enough
phenomenon to enter pop culture I
honestly just saw you
plastics
exactly how do you move is a great
future in plastics and the world started
to get a little more colorful and a lot
more varied it also brought culture to a
wider audience without plastics we
wouldn't have had film which really
brought theater in to more people we
wouldn't have had recorded sound I think
that plastics has made for a much more
equal world but then there was a shift
durable hard-wearing plastics made to
last where it Clips by throwaway
single-use plastics from the 1980s
plastic bags and bottles started become
commonplace their popularity came at an
environmental cost single-use plastics
are the focus of skies ocean rescue
campaign for the damage they do to our
waters Plastics changed the 20th century
profoundly the job of the 21st is
dealing with that legacy Tom Cheshire
sky news